well you wake up blind and you were in a  coma for all that time now you've said  yes yeah because when I think about my  daughter now mmm growing up without me  but a bit of disaster  you can't money can't fix that when I  first came on was in my wheelchair my  daughter one of my daughter she was a  baby so when I would pick up she stopped  crying and I started to take it personal  then my wife had to tell me Tracy she's  just scared to change the baby that's  right she's 11 months one month so let's  just get in the chair and I understood  but at 14 I got to see her walk that  night and I got it get out to cheer  myself I was not walking I wanna and I'm  my motivation for getting better I  didn't want to walk my wife down the  aisle with no cane